foreign
comes from Ashland in Texas I received a
student loan refund from the Relief act
pending the student loan discharge now
that the court has blocked the discharge
of loans should I send the refund back
to my lender for the loan
hmm Dave you know I love talking about
this it kind of feels like right now
it's like the wild west out there with
this whole student loan forgiveness act
I'm hearing things things about people
just getting these refund checks that
didn't even ask for refunds they're just
sending the money back even though they
didn't request it so and then some
people are asking for the money back so
for those of you who don't know
people who paid on their student loans
during covid since student loans were
paused they're eligible to ask for a
refund on that money in hopes that
student loan forgiveness will go through
but here's the thing it's not gone
through yet and I think a lot of people
are seeing these refund checks and
assuming that that's their money now
almost as if forgiveness has happened
and that all is okay but I really want
people to stop for a minute and realize
that that money until and unless
forgiveness goes through that's debt
they're just they're just putting you
back in debt with those refund checks so
if you have it's one more time that the
government used the wrong word
it's not a refund
it's not a refund
uh they just loaned you ten thousand
dollars more
yeah you had thirty thousand dollars in
debt
you would and now you have forty
thousand dollars in debt
well they sent money back that you paid
during covet I know and it's and you're
back in debt you're back in debt or
you're in debt more one of the two
whichever one it was but yeah so they
just put you back into debt
as of this moment in time
if they sent you ten thousand dollars
you now have a ten thousand dollar debt
it's not a refund
it was a loan they loaned you money
again right and and student loan
forgiveness it has not passed at this
point so it is so important that if you
got money back if you got that refund
check do not spend that money
don't spend that money
now if you want to send it back I mean
that's up to you again this is kind of
all new territory this is a very strange
situation for us what's the downside of
sending it back
the downside of sending it back nothing
right if they do forgiveness they're
going to send it back to you again there
you go if they don't do forgiveness
you're not screwed and in debt again
so send it back
well in the danger of keeping it is
you're dead you're in debt until they
pass all this crap and they get it
through you might be 96 years old when
they get this stuff through
and there's that Temptation that's
assuming you're 16 now by the way
there's that Temptation then to spend
that money oh no no yeah yeah yeah it's
not a Temptation it's a likelihood
um so yeah send it back
you ever get one of those things in the
mail from the Ripoff finance companies
you know like companies like beneficial
which isn't
you know you ever get those checks in
the mail it's like just deposit this
check yeah you ever seen those it looks
like a check when you flip it over it's
a 34 interest loan
and you can just deposit this thousand
dollars they sent you a check like it
was for a thousand dollars what was it
it was a loan at 34 from beneficial
who's not you know that's what it was
right that's what they're doing but
they're here to help you today they're
they're here to help we're we're from
the government and we're here to help
those are words that should chill the
very spine in your soul oh my gosh uh so
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah send it back
now uh let's see we got a February
supreme court date to rule on what the
lower court has already said that Biden
the student loan forgiveness program is
not valid okay Supreme Court has now
been asked to rule aren't they say
they're going to rule on it in February
um
and after they rule on it you know
what's going to happen
you have a republican majority in the
house and you have somewhat of a tie or
whatever the flip we want to call it in
the Senate and so
it's going to get all stirred up and
tied up in Congress because Congress the
Republicans are going to try to pass a
bill to keep Biden from doing this
and so it's going to get Frozen again
oh and then it's going to get Frozen up
you're going to be 96. you'll be 96
years old In This Crowd I'm not kidding
you
when we were a kid we used to say my you
know just redneck language it's like
well actually you're going to take an
act of Congress
what we were saying was it didn't likely
to happen
um
well this takes an act of Congress
probably
and it's not likely to happen so you do
what you want to do but you asked us
Ashland which is a dangerous thing
because we are experts in our opinion I
would send it back
well and here's the thing by sending it
back by not counting on this forgiveness
now now you don't have debt right what
do you have to lose you might lose they
might come out and go well the people
that all sent it back we're not going to
forgive theirs they might do that you
might you might lose some money but
let's see you already
owed the money
like you borrowed it
so oh well
uh Joe who's a welder and Susie who's a
waitress the taxpayers are bearing the
burden of this by the way and Joe who's
a welder and Susie who's a waitress who
didn't go to school and doesn't have any
student loan debt get to pay your debt
and you didn't they don't have to pay
yours because you had to pay your own
debt oh darn
I morally hate that you paid your own
debt and Joe the welder and Susie the
waitress didn't have to pay your debt
for you I really hate that for you
um that's just Dave you're not very
empathetic with the uh gen Z generation
they they need you to meet them where
they are I don't need to meet them where
they are I need I need you to I need you
to grasp what's going on right here it's
a moral obligation when you sign your
name to pay something that you go pay it
and when you don't pay it and the
taxpayer has to pay it that's unfair to
the taxpayer so give the refund back for
that reason and for the fact that these
dupers have put you back into debt again
and you're twirling on the end of their
string again
stop it yeah stop it you don't have to
you don't have to sit there and wait and
be anxious and be part of this whole
chaos right now you can watch the news
with uh or not watch the news and you'll
still be okay yeah see the only reason I
get any news is because James our
producer brings me news
because otherwise I don't put that crap
in my brain you're probably a happier
person oh I'm so much happier I got
consuming that stuff during covet and I
stayed so pissed off the whole time just
because I was watching all these people
being pissed off and it just pisses you
off and you just spend all your time
being mad why do I need this crap in my
brain so I scan Fox for about a minute
and a half in the morning just their
front page of their website and just see
what's going on so I kind of have a few
of the stories out there floating around
and then you guys bring me stuff in here
to do and other than that I'm not on
freaking Facebook and I'm sure not
reading Twitter
um and I'm for sure not a Tic Tac I mean
Tick Tock
um so you know I mean it's just my brain
is I'm such a nicer person now that I
did that y'all should have found me
before you think I'm mean now you should
have seen me back then so seriously it's
you got to watch your inputs uh and you
don't have to watch the news if you
don't have any student loan debt well
and with this stuff people are getting
pretty hot about it like on both sides
of what you just said I'm like Dave
you're stirring the pot like you're
gonna get something oh you mean people
are gonna react to me oh
such a new thing for you yeah I'm
stirring up a ruckus
here's the thing I've been doing it for
30 years and I've been helping you folk
because I love you and I want you to win
and I'm going to tell you the truth and
one of the things that causes you to win
is a high level of Integrity personal
Integrity pay the taxes that you owe I
hate taxes but I pay every single penny
I owe I do not cheat I do not lie on my
tax return not because the IRS is
wonderful not because Congress doesn't
suck neither one of those are true
Congress does suck and the IRS is not
wonderful that has nothing to do with my
integrity
whether I pay my taxes as my integrity
and if you want to win you got to have
integrity folks it's a long-term play
and so I love you enough to tell you the
truth have integrity it's one of the
things that causes people to win with
life and money it's an amazing thing
so if you know if that messes up your
Tic Tac well have at it this is the
Ramsay show